hello teachers Sal here from the
not-for-profit Kahn Academy and I just
wanted to thank you for all of your
partnership over the last ten years all
of us here at Kahn Academy it's much
more than me now we're over 200 folks
including researchers and teachers and
designers and we all recognize that the
most important actor in a student's
learning experience is you the teacher
and that's why we've been so excited to
partner with you over 700 thousand
teachers have registered for Khan
Academy and helped us reach over 74
million students there's over 1,200
translators who have helped translate
Khan Academy into over 40 languages that
are being used pretty much around the
world in over a hundred and ninety
countries and a lot of people think of
math when they think of Khan Academy and
we do have a lot of math but we've been
able to expand well beyond that into the
sciences the humanities computing and
the arts so I really want to thank you
for going on this journey with us I've
often said if I had to pick between an
amazing teacher and an amazing
technology I would pick the amazing
teacher every time but the good thing is
we don't have to make that trade-off our
goal is to try to empower you the
teacher with the tools you need to best
meet your students to save you time and
improve outcomes so that your students
learn more and become empowered citizens
for the world so thank you for being on
this journey with us and I really look
forward to seeing what we can do in the
next decade together